let's go next to roland from vienna is
that vienna austria
that it is david can you hear me i can
hear you fine
perfect yes yes yes uh i agree with the
previous caller i don't think it's
because they um that's the only way they
can formulate their thoughts but the
republicans the right wing in general as
we have over here they speak the
language of the internet much better and
they know it they know to use it to
to fool their uh their listeners better
than uh the left bus no i think you're
right i think you're right
listen uh i called him once before and i
dropped an f-bomb i want to excuse
myself for that because you asked me the
question about whether i like
cappuccinos
[Laughter]
and i quoted i quoted jimmy from philly
it said f your cappuccino right so
which brings me to my first point i want
to congratulate for you for a piece you
brought out um in the summer
i'm with doctor and i'm blanking on his
name where you talked with the doctor
and with jimmy from phillip oh dr k dr
alok
that man is a hero i listen to some of
the other stuff he does with these kids
uh online yeah he's great and very
revealing very very appealing about the
motivation for for where jimmy comes
from yeah
so that's it uh one point i want to make
two points the first one being
how putin seems to be um we know trump
loves them
we know uh fox news sides with them yes
are these guys aware that whenever
there's a mass shooting in russia
uh there's an assault rifle then
they probably are not aware of that no
they should be putin is one of the
toughest guys on gun control because he
knows the only way to control the
population is when they don't have one
which they always say no so
uh it's it's really ridiculous to see
how they're falling in love with him
when uh in reality he's pushing
a lot of things that they're not
comfortable with well it's ridiculous
for a lot of reasons and you've just
added one more
yeah and i see a lot of people asking
you to go back on joe rogan and to tell
him what's up and i think from a general
perspective i fully agree with that um
i've stopped listening to be honest i
was never a big fan anyway i'm in the
stand-up comedy so that was a good way
to get the news of the day in that field
but
uh he's hence the persona non grata in
my podcast feed wow
and specifically because this is
something that he always pushes so i'm
from austria i'm smack in the middle of
europe
we have socialized healthcare all the
countries around us we're quite happy
with it
and i always hear
um
from a lot of conservatives republicans
and all the mma guys on joe rogan
everyone's like oh if you're in if
you're in europe and you break your leg
you need to wait months to get it fixed
well yes if you if you want to get it
fixed socialized health care that uh
that pays for itself then you may you
may be on a waiting spot that's that's
true but i'm guessing you're you're not
going to need to wait months to be
stabilized from a broken leg right that
seems crazy no also
you know we do have a free market
healthcare system as well right parallel
so nobody is stopping you from dishing
out the money for out of your own pocket
yeah you can even get private health
insurance you can get to private
hospitals you can get hospital rooms
that are like hotels if you want to pay
for it yes
and that's the big discrepancy if you
want to pay for it you can have
everything but if you want to have it
socialized if you want to have it free
look if you can't afford it would you
rather wait for it a month to get the
hip replacement or would you rather not
get it you know of course of course and
i i i can really i can really feel
myself working up like i'm getting uh
yeah roland you're getting all worked up
you you need to go and have a cappuccino
uh not at this time of day but uh i'll
uh i'll have a nice smooth um
otherwise relaxing uh thing and uh that
should be nice
all right good roland from vienna you've
really said it all today thanks david
all right there it is rolling from
vienna wow
what a perfect way to cap off phone
calls this week i am sorry i can't ever
get to everyone
but i will try again when i see you back
here next week
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack giving you 20
off monk packs keto nut and seed bars
which taste just like your favorite
sweet snacks
but without the guilt because they have
only one gram of sugar two to three net
carbs and 150 calories a great snack if
you're doing keto if you're doing low
carb and if you just want a low sugar
snack i love the monk pack nut and seed
bars great balance of sweet and salty
satisfyingly crunchy soft and chewy
because i like these so much i use monk
packs subscription feature sends them
straight to my house on a regular basis
and saves me 10
if you don't love monk pack as much as i
do they will refund you all your money i
think there's a really good chance
monk pack nut and seed bars become your
favorite go-to snack
monk pack is giving you 20 off your
first order go to monkpack.com and enter
the code pacman at checkout